Cancer is not only a micro evolutionary
process as with standard biological
evolution,
micro evolution is a process that produces
a pattern macro evolution that we can
study with molecular filing genetics.
It turns out that the evolutionary history
of individual cancers is longer than
we had anticipated.
Cancer fight [inaudible] do
reveal some convergent evolution.
The heterogeneity revealed by phylogenies
is also pointing to problems for
therapies that are
targeted to single samples.
Yeah,
well I could or file a geography of
brain tumors shows that multiple clones
survive chemotherapy and that are
occupying different positions.
And this also points to
the complexity of therapy.
Analysis of phylogenetic trees of cancers
revealed that therapy with NSA ids,
nonsteroidal inflammatory drugs reduced
the rate of acquisition of somatic
mutations and that suggests
why Nsa ids reduce cancer risk.
We'll step through this.
Here is one study of a number of
patients who had pancreatic cancer.
And what you see here is a phylogenetic
tree sketched out running, uh,
from old to young,
from top to bottom.
It starts with a normal epithelial
cell in a doc in the pancreas.
Tumor cells starts with a mutation.
There was a process of clonal evolution
in which the dark blue clones were
eliminated by competition that
results in a parental clone.
What they mean here is parental for
the metastasis yields down a set of sub
clones that have metastatic capacity and
they then go out from the pancreas and
were recovered when the
patients died in lung and liver.
What could,
how long that took.
It took about 12 years for this
process of clonal evolution to go on.
Then about seven years for the sub clones
to build up with metastatic capacity
and from metastasis to death was
on average about three years.
Normally the cancer is not
detected until this point.
Okay,
so we usually think of pancreatic
cancers killing quickly,
but in these cases it started at least
18 years before the patients died.
So there was clonal selection
and the diagnosis came too late.
There was some local adaptation of
the metastasis to the lung into liver.
Okay.
Another example of acute
lymphoblastic leukemia.
What you have here is the ancestor and
the names that are given in the boxes are
labeling the ways that we
recognize the sub clones.
So this is the probable ancestor and
these are the origins of the different sub
clones.
They're from one cancer patient.
The numbers of copies in the different
clones is in front of the gene name.
So for example,
this is starting off with one copy here,
two of these, one of these and two
of these. And if you look down here,
you can see a clone which is
lacking any of those genes.
So they've been deleted and they've
also been deleted down here,
but it's picked up extra
copies of this gene.
So there are processes of
deletion and duplication,
which is are going on,
no single call replaced.
All of the others
there were had been repeated loss of
copy number variants and two genes packs
five and ETV six
and that generated a lot of genetic
heterogeneity, which hadn't in that case,
been completely resolved.
Here's a case of renal cell carcinoma
and this one is analyzed in great detail
and it shows that there's
been evolutionary divergence
among clones that are
persisting in that evolutionary divergence
poses real problems for therapy.
So a primary tumor in this case on the
kidney sent metasticies into the long end
of the chest wall.
Both the primary tumor and the
metastasis consistent of sets of clones.
They weren't simple.
They were genetically heterogeneous
therapies that were designed to treat the
primary tumor would miss the
variation in the metastasis.
So that would be an effective therapies
designed to treat one metastasis would
miss variation in the others.
Normally this is done by taking a biopsy
and the problem is that a biopsy would
normally be coming from
just one metastasis.
So they were sequenced and what you can
see here are you tations that are in
different samples.
So the samples are the roles
and the mutations are in jeans,
which are the columns and the ubiquitously
mutations are the ones which are
found in many different samples.
Then there are some shared primary
mutations which are shared among a few
samples in the primary tumor.
Then there are some shared
mutations in metastasis. However,
these are all of the
private mutations over here.
So these are found only
in individual samples.
Yeah,
so gray is the mutation is present.
Blue is that it's absent.
The purple gene names are that the
mutation was validated are these and the
orange gene names. It's where validation
failed. There were a few of those.
The point of the picture is
that in the cancer like this,
this is a kidney cancer, this
metastasized into the chest and lungs.
There's such a huge amount of genetic
variation that a sample from one part of
the primary tumor or from only one of
the metastasis is not going to give
characteristics that could lead to the
cure of the whole thing. It's too diverse,
so this was another way to look at all
of that genetic heterogeneity in that
kidney cancer.
Here we see a phylogenetic tree.
The mutations that are ubiquitous are
in blue and the branch length here is
proportional to the number
of non synonymous mutations.
So it basically is a measure of
how much selection is going on.
The potential driver mutations
are indicated by arrows here.
The shared primary or mutations
are along this orange branch.
The shared metastatic mutations are along
the screen branch and then the private
mutations,
the ones that are unique to individual
clones are in red point here is that we
need to treat the branches,
not the tweaks.
We need to be able to find
ways of targeting things
that are shared by all the
cells that are causing the problem.
Okay.
Another example comes from a Glioblastoma
and this was a molecular phylogenetic
investigation of a cancer
following chemotherapy.
The surviving population was
not a single resistant clone,
but there were multiple clones that
had different mutations for resistance.
Glioblastoma is a brain cancer,
okay?
Unless the treatments
eliminated all of the clones,
the survivors would persist
and probably flourish.
So again,
a single biopsy of one branch will not
be a sample that's sufficient to indicate
the problems that are posed by a tree.
There's another kind of a
useful information we can
gain about cancers using
phylogenetic methods.
So this again is the system in which
Barrett's esophagus progresses to a soft
geo with INA carcinomas.
And here we're using phylogenetic
inference to see how effective is therapy
using nonsteroidal inflammatory drugs,
anti inflammatory drugs.
In this case,
we have individuals that are indicated
by letters a through m and we can see
whether or not they were on or off the
NSA id and then look at the somatic
genomic abnormalities per genome per year.
So these are individuals who are
being followed, they're being sampled.
At some point they start getting treatment
with nonsteroidal anti inflammatory
drugs. Samples are being taken
from their Barrett's esophagus.
And in those samples we are looking at
what is the frequency of any kind of
somatic genomic abnormality.
So both point mutations,
abnormal chromosome numbers and so forth.
As this makes clear the drug reduced
the rate of the acquisition of these
abnormalities tenfold.
So athlete inflammatory drugs or reducing
the rates of mutation that lead to
cancer.
To summarize,
molecular phylogenetics can describe
the history of the evolution of a
metastatic cancer in a single patient.
Yeah.
The evidence for cancer is a process of
clonal evolution is now overwhelming.
Yeah.
Cancers originate earlier.
They are older than we had expected.
Single biopsies of primary tumors.
Seriously underestimate the clonal
heterogeneity of metastasis.
The are diff.
The heterogeneity is difficult to sample.
Yeah.
We have to, however,
treat the entire tree,
not the single branch that
sampled in a single biopsy.
Thus, phylogenetic inference is another
tool that we can use to evaluate the
effectiveness of preventive and
therapeutic medicine for cancer.